good morning John hi just up to my
calendar and I realized that there's no
freaking way I could possibly make video
next week because I'm gonna be all over
Los Angeles today on my tripod so I just
asked Twitter what I should do and I got
an amazing suggestion I'm up bro
zoom in clean up some of those laundries
real quick I'm and when I say clean up I
mean move from here to a little bit off
frame maybe be surprised to note that
Dave the fish is still here just not in
great shape so here's the idea I turned
on my mics and I sound better
it's from Morgan who says review
Broadway shows just based off their
descriptions on Wikipedia this is a
great idea this person should choose all
of my video topics hello Wikipedia
category Broadway musicals ah there's a
lot of a mouse-click a bunch see what
happened and where's the word the
website go American dance machine which
I assume is a musical about a robot made
in America that dances now there's a
bunch of other dancers in the musical
but just one robot this musical has a
lot lot of choreographers 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 choreographers need at this point
are the choreographers or are they robot
programmers banjo eyes although Cantor
was known as banjo eyes the title
referred not to his character but to a
talking racehorse slated costume by the
vaudeville team of Morton and Mayo ok
has songs like birthday Cod and
Valentine's Day God is also a number
called Mother's Day but not Mother's Day
card because this was before Mother's
Day cards oh this is this giant lists
have been looking at is just a B C and D
there's so many Broadway plays leaky
clicky clicky click it's a bird it's a
plane it's Superman
there's a Superman musical from 1966 why
didn't anybody tell me about this they
did a TV special in 1975 that on use is
that on YouTube it sure better be come
on oh it is oh it is the whole thing
this is less good than every YouTube
video oh my god it's beautiful
they should have sent a poet Leakey
clicky clicky open in my eyes
nothing happens the cocoanuts musical
the cocoa nut this is
coconuts and I'm just crazy it that wait
the more famous film adaptation was
released in 1929 let's see if that one's
available just just the preview for it
yes it's the cocoanuts Leakey clicky
clicky clicky I never know how okay
we've got one marriage a la carte that
sounds like a bad idea we got songs like
thrifty little mare silly cockadoodledoo
and of all her sex a paragon let's
listen to of all her sex a paragon
marriage a la carte Library of Congress
related items of all her sects of
Paragon sorry we can't find what you're
looking for it's been erased it's a
black file I just made up the term black
file but I think it's really good
maybe I didn't what's a black file black
file it's a nail salon are any other
songs Captain dinkle pop what's captain
tinkle paw how is there a song called
captain tinkle pop and I can't listen to
it
heads up Internet get on my level
Harwich ala carte gets 10 out of 10 ding
kebap sick click click Teddy and Alice
this is from 1987 fictionalized to
counter the relationship between Teddy
Roosevelt and his daughter Alice
pwetty and Alice suggested Roosevelt's
problems with his daughter stemmed from
an obsession with his late wife Frank
Rich of the New York Times compared it
to a halftime show at a high school
football game let's give that one just
like a zero teddy bears Morgan thanks
for the idea
hey everyone in the world you can spell
coconuts with an A if you want John
Congrats on turtles all the way down I'm
really proud of you I'm very excited for
it I'll see you what I'm getting we're
probably hanging out right now it's
VidCon bye